hey guys it's Wednesday March 23rd I'm
Mary and we're gonna do gamespot news
super fast today because I gotta go play
Dark Souls first up there was an Xbox
one update here's everything you need to
know March is Xbox one and Windows 10
Xbox update is now out for all users on
Xbox one two of the biggest new features
include 16 player party chat that used
to be 12 and the introduction of a store
where you can buy backwards compatible
Xbox 360 games which games you ask to
more Xbox 360 games have just been added
as announced today by Microsoft's Larry
Major Nelson herb the games are Dark
Souls and Tekken Tag Tournament 2 that's
a lot of T's a condensed version of
everything else you need to know I'll
put your party chat to headset and
speaker simultaneously customized game
DVR recording length track achievement
progress in the Xbox one guide video
playback directly in the Xbox one
Activity Feed gamer score leaderboard
Xbox 360 achievements in Xbox one and
Xbox app activity feeds compare your
avatar destinies April update is
incoming here's everything you need to
know Kings fall normal drops a bit
increase to light level 320 while hard
drops are boosted to light level 330
Court of Oryx artifacts drops meanwhile
will be raised to light level 335
additionally the prison of elders co-op
activity is getting boosted to level 41
providing players a new challenge there
will be a new activity titled challenge
of the elders which comes with a
scorecard that resets on a weekly basis
players who reach a score of 30,000
during the week will earn weapons while
reaching a cumulative score of 90
thousand will payout high-end armor the
original version of prison of elders
will remain available for players who
hate change
additionally winners run strike will be
increased to taken level difficulty for
the heroic strike playlist there's a
brand new quest and it's called at the
gate that's all I know about it please
stop asking I'll tell you more as soon
as I can finally Bungie confirmed that
April's update will come with further
tweaks to the game's crucible
multiplayer mode as well as unspecified
changes to the games overall sandbox
elements
additionally the update will deliver a
series of quality of life improvements
I'm sure you know what that means
finally I hope you got internet because
it's required to play battle born here's
everything you need to know
battleborn the upcoming shooter from
Borderlands creator gearbox software
will require players to have a constant
internet connection this is for the game
overall including single-player and
multiplayer in a statement to K games
explained one reason a constant
connection is required is because it
allows experience unlocked in the game
story mode to carry over to multiplayer
and the other way around
battleborn requires an internet
connection to play that's whether you're
playing single-player cooperatively with
friends or competitively against others
to kate old video gamer comm video gamer
also reported that battle borns ps4 box
states that a playstation plus account
is required for certain gameplay and
functionality as explained on the
PlayStation Blog a plus membership is
not required for the upcoming open beta
which was also announced today it
remains to be seen if the Xbox one
edition of battleborn will require an
Xbox Live Gold membership TLDR get
internet and that's all the news I have
for you today I'm gonna go play Dark
Soul 3 it's been so busy I haven't even
had time to eat